homeschoolers in high school going into
college drink less do less drugs are not
Partiers also academically our scores
are off the charts we're getting into
better schools the ivy league seek out
homeschoolers these days I remember
seeing home school kids as a kid and
they were always kind of weird that
would be my biggest concern what are
your thoughts about that I think it
comes down to the parents because
obviously if you keep your kid just
inside and you don't facilitate any
other kind of extracurriculars they're
not going to benefit from it and so
again it goes back to the parents of if
you are making this decision you are not
only taking on your children's academic
life you are taking on their social life
and you have to remember that because
just keeping them in their house that is
why you know they do not have a social
life outside of the home spending time
with Mom and Dad is great but you have
to be around other people